[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
das wird weiter geschossen und
bombardiert und es wird aber auch weiter
geredet heute griff wieder frankreichs
präsident ma con zum telefonhörer und
wanderern er verlangte von putin vor
allem die sicherheit der ukrainischen
atomkraftwerke zu garantieren und
förderte ihn dazu auf das vermutlich
bevorstehende bombardement der
hafenstadt odessa zu unterlassen die
küstenstädte im süden werden weiter
schwer umkämpft in maria poll muss die
lage der bewohner katastrophal sein eine
helle doch die menschen kommen aus der
stadt nicht raus dort beginnt domenik
löschmeister seinen bericht sie stehen
bereit für die evakuierung busse sollen
heute morgen zivilisten aus der von
russischen truppen belagerten hafenstadt
mario pohl bringen ins rund 200
kilometer entfernte la borussia um
200.000 menschen insgesamt soll es gehen
knapp die hälfte der bevölkerung
bereits gestern gab es einen versuch
aber die kämpfe dauerten an deshalb gab
es keine einzige möglichkeit sicher
durchzuführen
auch heute wird die feuerpause gebrochen
aktuelle bilder gibt es bisher nicht
wieder geben sich beide seiten die
schuld die lage in mario pohl ist
katastrophal seit tagen ist die stadt
eingekesselt im krankenhaus behandeln
sie verletzte unter schwierigsten
bedingungen immer wieder unter beschuss
wirst erlebte die hier arbeiten weiter
ohne strom wasser und heizung wir sind
unterversorgt es mangelt an schmerz mit
wir arbeiten hier alle zusammen schon
seit einer woche ohne pause
auch der bürgermeister richtete schwere
vorwürfe an russland
arbeiten systematisch daran die stadt
einzukesseln um hier ein humanitäres
problem zu schaffen damit die
bevölkerung ohne wasser essen licht
heizung und kommunikation bleibt
hauptfokus der russischen armee ist
neben mario pohl die umzingelung der
hauptstadt kiew
die russische luftwaffe fliegt weiter
angriffe bilder des
verteidigungsministeriums
außerdem sollen sich panzerkolonnen auf
kiew zu bewegen bei twitter werden diese
aufnahmen veröffentlicht sie sollen ein
zerstörten russischen konvoi zeigen
unabhängig zu überprüfen ist das alles
nicht schwer umkämpft weiter die stadt
ich bin nordwestlich von kiew der strom
der menschen die fliehen reißt nicht ab
dürfen unter dauerbeschuss vielen steht
der schrecken ins gesicht geschrieben
schockiert es war schrecklich
heftige kämpfe und ein entschlossener
bürgermeister ich kann sagen dass wir
von kiew nirgendwohin gehen jedes haus
jede straße jeder block wird bis zum
letzten atemzug verteidigt doch viele
zivilisten wollen raus aus der kampfzone
unter größter lebensgefahr
im eigenen dorf ist für uns in der
ukraine katrin was was hörst du wie
schwer ist das inzwischen überhaupt noch
aus diesem jahr besonders heftig
umkämpften städten im süden und osten
herauszukommen
hier so wie wir hören sind die
humanitären korridore eigentlich an
allen orten gescheitert immer wieder ist
es dazu gekommen dass menschen die sich
heraus getraut haben beschossen wurden
das konvois beschossen wurden busse aber
auch züge das teilweise konvois auch
zurückkehren mussten dass auch menschen
in ihren privaten autos beschossen
wurden die menschen haben die wahl
entweder sich auf diesen riskanten weg
zu machen oder eben in den städten
eventuell eingeschlossen zu werden und
dieser humanitären katastrophe
ausgesetzt zu sein auch hier in mit ski
wo wir jetzt gerade sind kommen immer
mehr flüchtlinge an in dem hotel in dem
wir sind kommen täglich neue menschen an
die hotels hier sind alle ausgebucht die
stadt hat so viele flüchtlinge dass sie
auch hier bei privatleuten und in
turnhallen unterkommen und was wir von
denen hören wenn wir mit ihnen sprechen
ist das der weg sehr beschwerlich ist
weil auf der strecke ganz ganz viele
checkpoints auch sind wozu riesenstaus
kommen die leute werden alle
kontrolliert das dauert einfach und das
ist eben auch eine zusätzliche gefahr
dann
benzinmangel ist auch ein problem ein
problem ist auch wenn familien mit
kleinen kindern oder alten leuten sich
auf die flucht machen das ist wirklich
ein drama was sich hier abspielt und
trotzdem machen sich immer mehr leute
auf die flucht richtung europa katrin
danke dir für deine eindrücke aus reiner
netz gehen
alle hoffnungen der ukraine richten sich
auf den westen aber welche möglichkeiten
hat er noch mehr waffen mehr sanktionen
fragen dich der bundes außenministerin
vor hingestellt habe vor dem gespräch
berichtet markus wolsiffer wie an diesem
wochenende weltweit hunderttausende
menschen auf die straße die in den usa
und südamerika in teilen asiens und
natürlich in europa
doch nicht nur in der freien welt gab es
solche demonstrationen sondern auch in
russland
kreml-kritiker navalny hatte aus dem
gefängnis heraus dazu aufgerufen und
tatsächlich gibt es in russland nach wie
vor menschen die sich das traum wohl
wissend was ihnen blüht
das z wir auf russischen
militärfahrzeugen hält der junge mann in
seinen händen nein zum krieg schreibt er
in cabaret die stadt liegt im südosten
russlands nahe der grenze zu china weit
weg von moskau doch putins regime ist in
diesen tagen ganz nach der demonstrant
abgeführt wie viele dies in russland
wagen den krieg öffentlich zu
kritisieren
nach angaben des russischen
innenministeriums wurden allein heute
3500 demonstranten in vielen städten
festgenommen
weltweit wächst der protest gegen
russland und putin wie heute auf dem
petersplatz im vatikan
viele gläubige hielten beim mittagsgebet
die fahne der ukraine und papst
franziskus wählte deutliche worte
[Applaus]
ströme von blut und tränen fließen in
der ukraine
es handelt sich nicht nur um eine
militär operation sondern um einen krieg
der tod zerstörung und elends mit sich
bringt
franziskus forderte ein ende des krieges
eine botschaft die heute aus vielen
ländern zu hören ist auf die straße
gingen die menschen etwa in thailand und
malaysia selten wird in südostasien für
ein europäisches land demonstriert so
groß ist die anteilnahme in diesen tagen
diese aggression ist nicht akzeptabel
man darf keine gewalt anwenden um seinen
willen durch zu drücken das ist die
botschaft die wir an alle senden wollen
weitere kundgebungen auch in europa in
spanien protestierten tausende einige
forderten ein stärkeres engagement der
nato in den größeren städten wie
barcelona madrid und la coruña haben
viele ukrainische wurzeln
wir fordern heute eine flugverbotszone
über der ukraine
damit nicht noch mehr zivilisten sterben
nicht noch mehr kinder sterben durch
raketen und
in deutschland da gingen gestern allein
30.000 in hamburg auf die straße heute
viele weitere demonstrationen überall in
mainz zum beispiel hälfte ukraine jetzt
morgen sei es zu spät steht auf einem
plakat ähnliche forderungen auch in
berlin wo mehrere tausend vor der
russischen botschaft demonstrierten
man ist sprachlos und fassungslos und
irgendwie muss man zeichen setzen man
kann er wenig dagegen machen und putin
wird nicht mitbekommen aber die leute in
der ukraine und die russen die sich in
moskau auf die straße trauen die welt
steht auf gegen putins krieg und die
vielen demonstrationen hier zu lande
werfen neue fragen auf über die
verantwortung deutschlands und wie sich
die bundesregierung weiter verhalten
soll während die kämpfe in der ukraine
toben
und die bundes außenministerin ist uns
zugeschaltet guten frau werburg guten
abend man hat gesehen auch heute bei den
demonstrationen alle fordern tut mehr
die ukraine erfordern helft uns mehr was
können sie mehr tun
ich glaub uns allen bericht dass das
herz weil jeder von uns kennt jemanden
der in der ukraine lebt manche die
großeltern die freunde oder wie bei mir
in dem fall politiker die ich tagtäglich
getroffen habe mit dem ich ständig im
austausch bin deswegen treibt auch mich
dieses gefühl um wir wollen alles tun
aber die forderung die jetzt auch zum
teil mit dem raum stehen sanktions
forderung
importstopp für alle fossilen energie
gebe es eine sanktion die morgen die
panzer stoppen würde wir würden sie
heute sofort ergreifen aber diese diese
maßnahme die sanktionen gibt es leider
nicht weil sich der russische präsident
in den kopf gesetzt hat dieses land
einzunehmen koste es was es wolle wenn
sie jetzt schon bei sanktionen sind es
gibt zum beispiel sanktionen gegen
russische banken aber da sind zwei unter
anderem die gazprombank von von
ausgenommen weil darüber deutschlands
und italien das gas geschäfte laufen ist
das nicht gefährlich man bei sowas dann
sich innerhalb der eu querlegt dass du
der eindruck erweckt mensch wir haben
die außenministerin die hält da große
flammende reden von den vereinten
nationen aber wenn es uns dann an den
geldbeutel geht dann kriegen wir doch
weiche knie
auch da muss man glaube ich ehrlich sein
weiche knie haben wir alle weil es ist
unberechenbar was der russische
präsident weiter truth deswegen legen
wir alles auf dem tisch es ist nichts
vom tisch genommen das sage ich hier
ganz klar und deutlich das wichtige ist
aber wie
sanktionen die wir jetzt auf den weg
bringen wirklich auch auf strecke halten
können weil es bringt nichts zu sagen
wir machen morgen der sanktionen und
eine woche später nehmen wir sie wieder
zurück wenn im zweifel noch weiteres
schlimmes in der ukraine passiert ist
weil wir sie nicht durchhalten können
wir schauen und so auch die beiden
banken an die sie angesprochen haben wie
wir es schaffen können auch dort weiter
vorzugehen der punkt ist und ich finde
wichtig dass das auch allen bewusst ist
dass wir in deutschland aber auch in
europa insgesamt massiv von russischer
energie abhängig sind das haben sich
jetzt nicht die grünen ausgedacht wir
haben seit langem deutlich gemacht hätte
er auch mehr unabhängigkeit aber das ist
schnee von gestern wir sind jetzt in der
realität von heute aber was soll damit
deswegen alles passieren wenn man sagt
okay
erdölimporte sofort stoppen gas sofort
stoppen ist ja nicht bei uns sofort alle
lichter ausgehen wenn
wir das alle sofort vom netz nehmen
würden schon wenn wir uns anschauen
gerade bei der kohle wir sind mit blick
auf die steinkohle 50 prozent der
importe kommen aus russland und
kohlekraftwerke produzieren strom und
produzieren wärme bei uns und in anderen
ländern deswegen ist mein kollege robert
habeck auf hochdruck daran mit blick auf
gas alternativen einzukaufen beim öl
auch und wir schauen jetzt werden zum
beispiel schrittweise vorgehen kann dass
wir nach und nach auch hier den stecker
ziehen aber es hat eine
gesamtverantwortung wir werden den krieg
nicht stoppen können dadurch dass bei
uns in europa komplett das licht
ausgehen mir also ich möchte auch mal
deutlich machen dass das zerreißt mich
das zerreißt uns alle in der
bundesregierung aber müssen obwohl und
diese bilder vom bombardierten städten
das herz zerreißt immer auch einen
kühlen kopf bewahren weil wir tragen
eine gesamtverantwortung natürlich
zuallererst mit blick auf das leiden den
tod in der ukraine aber eben auch dafür
dass in deutschland in europa wir nicht
und durch schritte selber härter ins
knie schießen
rezession riskieren dafür der rezession
werden wir haben das erleben wir jetzt
schon und wir sind bereit das habe ich
ja immer wieder deutlich gemacht einen
sehr sehr hohen wirtschaftlichen preis
zu zahlen nur wenn morgen in deutschland
in europa die lichter ausgehen heißt das
nicht dass die panzer stoppen wie gesagt
wenn das der fall wäre wir würden es
sofort tun aber wenn wir jetzt weitere
schritte ergreifen und wie gesagt wir
bereiten weitere sagen zu uns maßnahmen
vor dann müssen wir bereit sein das auf
dauer auch zu tragen weil das was der
russische präsident macht mit dem
einmarsch aber auch mit bruch des
völkerrechts das muss konsequenzen auch
auf dauer haben und diese sanktionen
müssen alle das muss allen klar sein
auch auf strecke halten sie sagen auf
dauer gehen sie davon richten sich
darauf ein dass er das sehr lange
durchhalten wird die ukraine
die haben ja sehr konkrete forderungen
die sagen auch unseren korrespondenten
und den reportern die sich der ukraine
bewegen bitte schützt unseren luftraum
ja weil das wäre das effizienteste
mittel auch mit blick auf humanitäre
korridore den flugraum schützen oder
eine flugverbotszone das klingt erst mal
defensiv wenn man denkt dann fallen
keine bomben mehr aber in der praxis
würde es bedeuten den flugraum zu
sichern dass wir also die nato russische
flugzeuge abschießen würde so könnten
wir den luftraum nur schützen und das
würde bedeuten würden aktiv in diesen
krieg eingreifen und auch hier ich kann
mich nur wiederholen aber so schmerzlich
ist die situation gerade wenn wir jetzt
in diesem krieg mit eingreifen würden
dann kann niemand die hand dafür ins
feuer legen dass dieser krieg nicht auf
das andere das restliche auf unsere
teile europas überschwappen
akw in die luft fliegt
dass das kann genauso passieren deswegen
sind wir mit hochdruck mit blick auf die
flugverbotszone dran gegenüber dem
russischen präsidenten der bundeskanzler
hat mit ihm ja auch nochmal direkt
gesprochen humanitäre korridore wo klar
ist die geflüchteten die kommen sind
hier sicher auch mit blick auf das
atomkraftwerk ich war in der nacht als
es passiert ist damit meinen leuten rund
um die uhr die minuten waren es dran mit
der iaeo der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde zu telefonieren um
sicher zu stellen wie können wir das
schützen auch da sind wir in gesprächen
obwohl wir alle kanäle gekappt haben
sind wir in gesprächen mit der
russischen seite deutlich zu machen
diese atomkraftwerke die können nicht
angegriffen werden es würde auch nach
russland überschwappen und ich glaube
das ist das wichtige immer wieder
deutlich zu machen dieser krieg den der
russische präsident gegen die ukraine
führt der ist auch ein krieg der sich
gegen sein eigenes volk wendet er
ruiniert ein eigenes volk damit und
sowie die menschen jetzt auf die straße
gehen der beitrag vorher hat sehr
deutlich gemacht es ist unglaublich die
leute werden verhaftet ihn wird
angedroht ihr kommt auf jahre ins
gefängnis und trotzdem sagen sie das ist
nicht unser krieg und ich glaube das ist
wichtig auch hier in deutschland immer
wieder deutlich zu machen das ist nicht
der krieg von russinnen und russen
sondern er kann ja eines russischen
präsidenten noch ganz kurzen schluss die
frage ihr amtskollege aus den usa
blinken hat zu erkennen gegeben heute
abend im interview sie enden zdf das
vorbereitungen getroffen werden eine
exilregierung eine ukrainische
einzurichten die dann quasi einspringt
in dem moment wo präsident die linzer
etwas passieren sollte können sie das
bestätigen
wir bereiten alle möglichen szenarien
vor das habe ich ja deutlich gemacht mit
blick auf die sanktionen dass wir alles
prüfen uns alles genau anschauen und
auch alle anderen maßnahmen schauen wir
uns genau an aber klar ist wir stehen an
der seite dieser ukrainischen regierung
sie verteidigen irland mit allem was sie
haben der präsident ist selber vor ort
der außenminister alle sind vor ort um
ihrer land irland zu verteidigen weil
das ist ein kampf um freiheit und daher
ist es so wichtig dass wir die
ukrainische regierung unterstützen auch
das wurde von unterschiedlichen staats
und regierungschefs der welt die
israelische war ja auch gerade vor ort
deutlich gemacht das ist die legitime
regierung der ukraine und die
weltgemeinschaft steht hinter dieser
regierung danke schon vor berbalk fürs
gespräch danke ebenso alles gute
über den krieg in der ukraine werden
später auch maybrit illner und ihre
gäste noch ausführlich reden in einer
spezialausgabe an diesem sonntagabend
jetzt macht heinz wolf erstmal weiter
mit anderen meldungen
bundeswirtschafts- und
klimaschutzminister harbeck hat sich im
interview mit der zdf sendung berlin
direkt unter anderem zum thema
energiesicherheit geäußert und da auch
zur frage ob er für das endgültige
atomausstieg eine verlängerung denkbar
ist ich bin natürlich dafür den ausstieg
aus der atomkraft möglichst schnell zu
vollenden wir haben falls die
lieferketten aus russland reißen eine
herausforderung für den nächsten winter
im frühjahr das frühjahr und den sommer
werden wir gut bestehen können aber der
nächste in thal bereitet mir noch ein
bisschen sorgen wir prüfen deswegen
obwohl ich natürlich für den ausstieg
aus der atomenergie bin ob ein längerer
betrieb der atomkraftwerke irgendwas
nützen würde aber nach dem was man
absehen kann ist das nicht der fall
die kreditkartenanbieter visa und
mastercard stellen ihr russlandgeschäft
vorübergehend ein die unternehmen
erklärten in russland ausgestellten
karten würden damit außerhalb des landes
nicht mehr funktionieren und karten von
ausländischen banken nicht mehr in
russland am abend hatte auch american
express mit seine aktivitäten in
russland auszusetzen
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine und
jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190 immer mehr menschen
aus der ukraine suchen zuflucht auch in
deutschland offiziell registriert sind
hierzulande inzwischen fast 38.000
schutzsuchende insgesamt sind laut un
bislang mehr als 1 5 millionen menschen
aus der ukraine geflohen vor allem die
angrenzenden nachbarländer im westen ja
von denen die es raus schaffen kommen
die meisten nach polen unter anderem
nach wort das uns im deutschen unter dem
namen breslau vertraut ist was lange
statt an der sich die ganze geschichte
unseres kontinents erzählen lässt die
geschichte von zerstörung flucht
vertreibung und dem aufbau neuer heimat
das historische breslauer lag 45 in
schutt und asche die stadt wurde dann
neu gebaut auch mit häusern die
mittelalterlich oder barock aussehen an
der stelle aber sony standen und es
wurden heimatlos amt heimatlos gewordene
angesiedelt so entstand etwas ganz
eigenes neues heute ist wrestler ein
tummelplatz für touristen und jetzt
kommen die flüchtlinge wie sie empfangen
werden erzählt conny schiemenz
viele viele kinder und weinende mütter
am bahnhof von breslau den polnischen
france wurf kommen tausende flüchtlinge
an jeden tag die hilfsbereitschaft der
polen ist überwältigend essen eine neue
handy karte ein warmes bett organisiert
von tausenden freiwilligen
vor allem brauchen wir
dieses gefühl
einfach das wort
dass jemand kommt und einfach umarmt und
sagt ich bin hier und ich bin eher dafür
fertig ich helfe dir
ruslana ist mit ihren zwei kindern aus
der ost ukraine geflohen allein ihr mann
blieb zurück sie wünscht sich nichts
sehnlicher als frieden für die ganze
welt
wir sind die ganze zeit nur in gedanken
in der ukraine in unserer heimat bei
unserer familie wir wissen nicht wie es
weitergeht
für ihren dreijährigen sohn andreas die
welt zusammengebrochen gestrandet am
bahnhof von breslau ein schicksal wie
das von igor salomon auch er war ein
flüchtlingskind auch er kam aus der
ukraine nach breslau vor 70 jahren
geschichte die sich wiederholt
es ist schrecklich wenn ich jetzt all
diese bilder sehe die gesichter der
kinder
deshalb versuchen wir auch zu helfen wo
es nur geht wir haben eine schule
gegründet und wir helfen mit psychologen
ganz breslau hilft denn hier weiß man
was es heißt vertrieben zu sein fast
jeder hat vorfahren die einst aus
anderen teilen polens oder eben aus der
ukraine kamen im gemeindehaus der
griechisch-katholischen kirche formen
sie seit kriegsbeginn piroggen rund um
die uhr polnische und ukrainische frauen
gemeinsam
wir frauen können hier nicht kämpfen
deshalb kam uns die idee mit dem
piroggen das sind unsere waffen von dem
geld was wir einnehmen kaufen wir
medikamente und andere hilfsgüter
polen wächst in dieser krise über sich
hinaus nimmt flüchtlinge auf wo es sonst
blockierte für facher dem venue keine
überraschung der krieg ist in europa
in der ukraine die an holen grenzt und
natürlich haben auch die leute die hier
wohnen haben angst vor russland und
dann singen sie aus ganzem herzen die
ukrainische nationalhymne für die
freiheit
[Musik]
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit anderen
themen dieses tages zur aktuellen kroner
lager in deutschland die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist im wochenvergleich
erneut gestiegen das robert koch
institut meldet 116
1889 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
acht
1976 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei 1.200
31,1
in osnabrück ist heute die woche der
brüderlichkeit zur christlich jüdischen
verständigung eröffnet worden für ihr
engagement gegen antisemitismus und
rassismus haben der präsident von
eintracht frankfurt peter fischer und
der jüdische sportverband makabi
deutschland bei einem festakt die
buber-rosenzweig-medaille erhalten die
aktionswoche steht unter dem motto
fairplay jeder mensch zählt
zum sport ein ergebnis aus der fußball
bundesliga
hoffenheim hat beim 1 fc köln mit 1 zu 0
gewonnen und beim biathlon-weltcup in
finnland kam einzelnen olympiasiegerin
denise herrmann heute erneut aufs podest
wenn auch nicht nach ganz oben wie
gestern im sprint heute gab es in der
verfolgung rang drei hinter der
norwegerin tiere eckhoff und dorothea
wierer aus italien und bei den männern
holte erik lesser ebenfalls in der
verfolgung platz zwei nur der franzose
thierry omeyer war schneller
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten der
montag beginnt im südwesten sonnig
später scheint auch im norden oft die
sonne nach osten hin bleibt es wolkig
meist aber auch trocken die temperatur
erreicht zwei bis neun grad am dienstag
gibt es nur wenige wolken ab mittwoch
scheint überall die sonne allmählich für
das wärme mit südlichem wind steigt die
temperatur am donnerstag auf 7 bis 15
grad
das was von uns über alle aktuellen
ereignisse halten wir sind natürlich
weiter auch online auf dem laufenden
aufzählte erfolg und um 0.30 gibt es
dann die nächste heute express und im
heute-journal erwarten sie morgen abend
hier christian sievers und anna
zimmermann wir sagen auf wiedersehen